Hello, I'm Gavin
I'm Dan
We are the Slow Mo Guys.
And you may have noticed it's the middle
of the night.
What does that mean Dan?
We usually, when we're
filming we use the sun
to light our subject.
But today our subject
creates its own light.
So it's better to do in the dark
Don't even need the sun
because it's Texas in the summer,
we're stood out here at one in the morning
in shorts and a T-shirt
Still sway
Still sway.
This video is sponsored by Google.
And to help us make it.
We're gonna be using
the Google Pixel 3a XL,
You'll find out more about it in a bit.
We've done a video before
where I was spinning wire wall,
Yeah,
In the night
And I thought,
how do we escalate that?
And then I thought we've got two arms.
But why stop at two?
You've also got two legs.
So the then I thought that's
just me spinning around.
And there's a machine
that does that already.
Yeah, me just going like this.
So you found a machine with four limbs.
Yeah, funny that it's a shop fan.
That I've hooked up here and
taking the outside off of
This is comical, and I'll be honest,
we have not tested this in the slightest
No idea if it's gonna work.
Absolutely none.
I think we should just plug
it in and see what works.
That's probably for the best.
All right, it's a dangerous one.
Don't try this at home.
Yeah
What do you got safety wise?
Well, because we're
obviously dealing with sort
of burning metal sparks
gonna put this fireproof suit
on or fire resistant suit on,
to help me protect me from the heat
as well as a balaclava and some gloves,
and some goggles, so that
the sparks can't find
their way to my skin.
I said balaclava to an American recently,
and they thought it was
some kind of desert.
Balaclava what do you mean?
I will also be in a protective suit
cause I'm actually
probably more in the line
of fire than you are.
Yes you are, cause the wire wool
is gonna be spinning
away from me into you.
Yeah,
I think I remember the
last time we were doing
this I was fine, and you were just like,
This is raining down on my head.
So first of all, Dan is just gonna spin it
on his hand again, like last
time as a little refresher,
and I'm gonna use the
pixels night sight feature.
Because I've heard it has
great low light capability
for us still almost like a long exposure,
so we'll see if I can see him
once we turn this light off.
Are you already, feeling ready.
I'm feeling pretty ready
All right.
It's gonna be so bloody dark
It really is, oh my god, oh
Okay go for it.
It's lovely still works well
Yeah it does look at
That is cool I've always wanted
to get pictures like that with my phone,
always I've never been able to.
It looks like a human Catherine
wheel for this subject
as we learned last time
we are gonna film it
in a slightly different way to usual
with a lower frame rate
and a very high shutter angle as big
as we can get about 359 degrees.
So that each frame will be full
of motion blur, and those
streaks will be as long
as possible if we did
a higher shutter speed
one eighth either or where we usually are,
our trails will be cut in half.
And if we go all the way
up to 1000 frames a second,
they won't be trails, there'll be dots.
You've got like an 80
foot shadow behind you.
It's pretty cool.
All right, you ready?
Turn the lights off.
Lights off.
Whoa
You all right.
Whoa, was that good?
Yeah, that was class didn't speed up
once they all flew up.
Yeah.
Oh, that's class.
Wow, you can see the bits flying off
and then landing on stuff.
There's no way that I could
achieve that as a person.
Well, you don't own a bank
No I don't that's true.
As they kept flying off it was like
they kept like moving around like it was,
heavier at certain points
and I was like, oh god,
it's like
Oh look at that bit
Let's just weigh this
its throwing everything
there they take turns, don't they
Yeah
A little bit nervous about this one
Oh me too,
You'll be all right, what,
I'm just prompting
cause I can't see anything
and I don't want to step on any rock.
There it is, you're ready?
Yeah.
Oh bloody Oh, bloody,
whoa, it's so painful,
okay that really hurts
Is it really?
Its like pepper on my legs
I guess it go straight through the soon.
Really isn't very temporary though.
Oh yeah it's like a bunch of tiny knives
Okay, but a playback
That's sick
Yeah,
It looks like I'm doing it with my hands
Yeah it looks like you've got
like elite ploy skills ?
Hold the camera steady for goodness sake.
Not that was trying to get you anything
but I was definitely trying to get you
Yeah, well so i was a really going
for a Dutch angle here.
That's why I wanted Oh yeah,
I was thinking battlefield Earth.
It was a stylistic choice.
Yeah of course.
This episode always wins it again
but like camera it just
peppered me into it
In the crotch area.
I don't think I even need
safety gear for this.
Oh.
Look at that one it blast at the bottom
of the lens play hit the hood.
I wonder if I could be
under there with you.
Do you think I'd be right?
Oh, you'd be fine.
I mean, the only danger is
these huge globs of forces
If I was just at your
legs looking up at you.
Oh, that would work.
That'd be all right, wouldn't it?
That would work
what is going on
If i hold it up like this?
It's about three in the morning.
And when were back in a quarry.
Ready?
Yep.
Oh, oh my god.
Oh man play
Oh where am I?
There looks like I'm
holding up a plate of dew
there was a couple of
Yeah I remember that.
There was a couple of
sparks that went down
I was watching.
Like I'm showing you
from like fireworks.
I was having fun, look how safe is that
It's perfect.
I didn't get any sparks from you at all.
All going away from them.
And I'm protected by the wood,
if something just did go wrong
Really attracting a lot of bugs.
Well, we got a huge big light.
It's true,
And there's no moon or
any other lights off.
All right, what are
you gonna do this time?
I wanna spin it around in
all kinds of directions.
Just go a bit nuts with
it balaclava background.
Balaclava in that background
cause it's going everywhere.
Yeah really kicked off at the end.
It really did, those have gone miles away
Those ones that were
ends up directly coming
towards the camera they end
up so big they smell flare.
Yeah, they just like smash
it dropping right in front of it look
and then like some
of them I think I aimed directly at you at
one point there's just
sparks flying straight at you
That's cool when it goes behind you
and you're just a silhouette.
Yeah, that is cool.
Like I'm back lit by the sparks.
What about this, will take
the pixel that google,
lovingly sent us and tape it
onto the fan facing out.
Get a crazy shot sort of POV blade.
Of all the sparks shooting outwards.
Do they want this phone
back or we might be able
to give it back in one piece.
Okay, well let's try it.
Oh dear, whoa
Is it a bit a, a bit wobbly.
Yes, its a wobbly
You just lit around.
It stayed on the fan.
I tilted it down slightly
so I could get more
of the, the metal filing
It looks like a plane wing.
Whoa,
The sound effect is perfect, isn't it?
You don't need to do any
Foley's, it's like amazing,
You those old sci-fi
movies where it's like oh,
you know will go to warp
speed all the stars like
Yeah, yeah, yeah
From the side window that's the angle.
Did you hear the rattling of the Fang?
That was when it was like getting up
some serious speed.
I think we got some magnificent
looking footage there.
I just have to call to attention the fact
that you're wearing your safety gear
around your ankles like you're
about to get it
Well they can't see, I saw it right
before we started filming it
just sort of went, appeared
up and I just stood in the drain gear .
Imagine what it looks like
when a man takes his trousers off
and like puts them on the toilet.
It looks like that
I just thought I could get away with it ,
until you called it out.
I think we got some really
nice looking footage.
I really love the dome effect.
I made a big difference
because usually I had the
one but with this i had four
in a minute the sparks
were all directions.
I much preferred four it was just like a
solid sheet, 360 sheet of sparks.
Thought it was wonderful,
big old thanks to Google for sponsoring
this video had a lot of
fun using the pixel 3a XL,
I was very impressed by
the night sight mode.
I don't know how it works,
but it must use stabilization
to take the long exposure
I've only ever done
one exposure on tripods
because doing this you get
this all blurring the whole
thing it somehow stabilizes.
One thing I noticed the darker the picture
is the longer it takes to take an image.
So there's some some cool tech going on
there don't know how--
Someone smarter than you is the--
Work that they put some time in.
I always felt like the fast
charging when I put it in
when we first got it,
it told me how long it was going to take
and it said charging rapidly
or charging fast and it
was just super quick.
We've got a second channel.
Subscribe to that one.
Subscribe to this one, there's a bell.
Hit us up on the socials.
Anything else?
Yeah, I'm going to start
trying to fill up Google
and just
Taking pictures
Recording everything.
We'll see you in the next video.